let's talk about the good place a second
because you play this artificial being
on the show and it's hilarious role
because you're really supposed to be I
mean I don't know how to describe it
almost like a highly evolved Siri or
Alexa yeah yeah and and you're it's such
a you play it so well you're so put on
in
you're so funny playing this role and
and but I'm just curious like what is
that what is it how has that informed
your life playing that role weird thing
is that like Syrian elects are such a
big part of our lives and I think that
playing Janet Janet there's her name
it's like tapped me into some sort of
like robot brain where I don't want to
use Syrian Alexa anymore because it's
like mixing two things people are also
like really rude to their series and
Alexis have you noticed that I have all
people just they don't think of that as
what well I don't know I just think
they're I'm I like to try and be polite
me too and so but I but I do I try to be
polite and so it's when I'm just like
call Oh
so nacelle like pulling my assistant
herself call so to work it yeah yeah I
am I
yeah I I often say please and thank you
and then it like Mike misses it it
doesn't work for me so I don't use it I
even like stopped being friends with
somebody because of the way they treat
it there Alexa for real that's weird
I'm sorry that's really weird I heard
the way you spoke to Alexa - Alexa
well I'm waving apologize to me she was
very rude she screamed at her LexA in
front of a whole party and I was like
we're done yeah we're done no one treats
a soulless machine like that I feel
you